- [Instructor] So let's
say that I have matrix A
and its elements.
It's a two-by-two, a, b, c, d.
We have a lot of practice
taking determinants
of matrices like this.
The determinant of this matrix,
same thing as determinant of a, b, c, d.
It's going to be equal to a
times d, ad, minus b times c.
Now what would happen
if we multiply one row
of this matrix by a constant?
What would happen to its determinant?
Well, let's try it out.
So you have your original,
the determinant of your
original matrix, a, b, c, d.
I'm just rewriting what
I just did up here.
That's ad
minus bc.
Now if I were to multiply,
let's say, this first row by a constant k,
how would that change the determinant?
Well, instead of this being
just an a, this is now a ka.
And instead of this being
just a b, it is now a kb.
And so this is equal to k times
ad minus bc,
which is the same thing as
it's equal to k
times our original
determinant of our matrix A.
So that seems pretty interesting,
and I encourage you to see that if you,
instead of doing the first
row, you did the second row,
you would have gotten the same outcome.
And then you could also verify that look,
if I multiply both of these
rows by that constant k,
how would that change things?
Well, then I'm gonna have ka times kd,
so you're gonna have
a k squeezed in there.
And then you're gonna have kb times kc.
And so this would actually be,
you could factor out a k squared.
And so this is going to be k squared
times the determinant of A.
And that can be extended to
a generalized property that,
if I have some
n-by-n matrix A,
then the determinant,
the determinant of k
times that n-by-n
matrix A,
the determinant of this,
when I multiply a constant
times all, entire matrix,
I'm multiplying that
constant times all the rows,
we could say all of the elements.
Well, this is going to be equal to,
pause this video.
See if you can intuit
what this general formula is going to be.
You might be tempted to say it's k
times the determinant of A,
but remember that's only
if I multiply one row by k.
But if I multiply the entire matrix by k,
well, then this is going,
this determinant is going
to be the constant k
to the nth power
times the determinant
of our n-by-n
matrix A.
And you could see this play
out in a three-by-three case.
In fact, I encourage you to try it out
with some three-by-threes.
And you could also do a generalized proof
for an n-by-n case, but
I won't do that now.
This is really just to give you the idea.